tonight a woman who says she was left
for dead after a gruesome attack in a
Downtown parking garage is speaking out
this says the suspects in the case are
expected to appear in court this week
it's a story 8 news now reporter
Victoria Saha has been covering
exclusively for us we do want to warn
you some may find the images in this
story disturbing
[Music]
shot at almost unheard of their intent
was to kill me it was the end of a fun
night for this Las Vegas woman who just
wants to go by the name Kim I was trying
to go home in the early morning hours of
April 30th Kim and her friends were
walking to their car on the fourth floor
of the Binion's parking garage when
suddenly someone stole her friend's
necklace Kim says after the robbery she
and her friends took off towards the
first floor exit of the garage when a
car with the same group of people who
just robbed them stood in their way Kim
got out to see what was going on that's
when she says they ran her over three
times my body has no traction so the
tires is literally just spinning on my
body it didn't just stop there they shot
her twice I could hear the gunshots but
I can't like my mind was just it didn't
care I was just trying to not get my
head squished the perpetrators then
drove off do you think they left you Dad
they sure did Kim was rushed to the
hospital where her injuries would leave
her paralyzed for three days now almost
a month later she's at home trying to
recover but her scars are a reminder of
the long road ahead I can't cough sneeze
hiccup nothing
without it like piercing me Kim hired an
attorney who says this attack could have
been a prevent it if there was help
around not once does anyone encounter a
security guard not one point is a member
of Binion's team you know intervened its
negligence on their part and for this to
happen the way it happened as for the
people that did this police arrested
three suspects later they were just
trying to continue on with their life
well they probably think they ended one
I think they think they killed me
Victoria Saha eight news now the
suspects will face a judge Tuesday
morning Kim will be out of work for
several months but her family has set up
a GoFundMe to help